[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
welcome walter welcome to you too my
friend
how have you been i'm fine my wife says
i mustn't wear grey because i look like
a grey little man in a gray little suit
well you look quite decent i'll go with
that one as well
but i skyped before she could stop me
you'll get it when you get back i think
i'll be okay
well today is a very important subject
so we'll need the guidance of the holy
spirit let's pray
our heavenly father we discuss
today one of the most important subjects
it's about the great controversy and
would you enlighten our minds
and enlighten the viewers and help us to
discern in jesus name
amen amen
so martin there are so many people that
ask
who is michael how does he fit into the
contest with lucifer
where does jesus fit in and uh
yeah they seem to think that the
adventist view
is totally haywire yeah it's one of the
most
controversial points that people out
there
pinpoint on the adventist church saying
that their view of michael
is totally actually blasphemous
yes so it's important because there's a
lot of people that
get stuck on this that's right so we we
need to look at it very carefully
and uh i think we should jump right in
yes as we normally do all right so
we've titled this one michael the
archangel
versus lucifer son of the morning
now these are titles that you find in
the king james version of the bible
yes it's interesting that the title
archangel associated with michael only
appears
twice in the bible in fact the word
archangel
only appears twice and both times it is
associated
with michael so let's start on the
opposite end who is lucifer
son of the morning
if we go to the book of isaiah chapter
14 and we read there from 12
12 it says how art thou fallen from
heaven o
lucifer son of the morning and how art
thou
cut down to the ground which did weaken
the nations
for thou said in thine heart i will
ascend into heaven
i will exalt my throne above the stars
of god i will
sit also upon the mount of the
congregation in the sides of the north
i will ascend above the heights of the
clouds i
will be like the most high
yet thou shalt be brought
down to hell to the sides of the pit
now if we look at this verse it's
actually
quite interesting it tells us about
lucifer
who was part of the heavenly realm
and then he fell he was perfect
the bible says until iniquity was found
in him
in other words he was created perfect
with the freedom of choice
and when he enabled that freedom of
choice to
choose against righteousness
and truth that's when he fell
so god didn't create him to fall he
exercised a choice to fall
you know martin if you read this there
are six eyes
it is i will ascend into heaven
i will exalt my throne above the stars
of god
i will sit upon the mount of the
congregation in the sights of the north
i will ascend above the heights of the
cloud
and i will be like the most
high so here is the angel that exalted
himself
and wanted to be in the congregation of
the north he wanted to
be part of the throne of god so he
wanted to be elevated to the position of
god
yes and that cost him his place
in heaven and all who sympathized with
him
one third of the angels just a question
i don't know if this will take you on a
side track
that lucifer fall
before or after the creation of the
earth
well i believe that lucifer fell
before the creation of the earth
or during the plan
to create the earth when the plan was
conceived to create the earth
that's when rebellion came to a head
in heaven and he was cast out
now why did god create man
as a solution to the sin problem now
we've dealt with this in previous one so
we're not going to go there again
but the point is that the world
that is now also in a fallen state
has developed the same mindset as the
great deceiver
and this ideology that man
can inherently rise to the level of
deity
is part and parcel of the thinking
of a great portion of humanity yes
it's even within many church
ideologies it's encased in those
ideologies
and the whole new age movement and
theosophy
and all of them are actually in sympathy
with the devil
it's interesting there are rock
musicians who
sing songs sympathy with the devil
and some of these individuals are
knighted
which is a very strange occurrence yeah
so
strange saying that you're got sympathy
for the devil and then you get knighted
along with it that's very interesting
interesting and
hollywood is of course famous for making
movies
and series on this issue
and uh there was there was a series
called
lucifer and lucifer was
very very popular i mean they got
millions and millions and millions of
views
and in the entire movie he is portrayed
as the villain
but in such a brilliant way that your
sympathy
is with the devil and that's the same
sort of idea
as the open rebellion that you find in
the rock world
yes so let's have a look at the clip out
of this
series this is lucifer
on youtube
people like to tell me things those deep
dark naughty little desires that are on
their mind
hey boss remember me can i have your
autograph did i
sell my soul to the devil so the devil
made you do it did he
the alcohol and the drugs the top the
selfies the choices are on you my dear
lucifer morning star is that uh stage
name
god-given i'm afraid stop caring you're
the devil
your return to the underworld has been
requested let me just uh check my
calendar here it is the
seventh of never through to the 15th of
ain't gonna happen how does that work
for you guys
try it you think father's upset now he
will not be merciful for much longer we
should be out there punishing those
responsible come on i help you
how could you possibly help me i have
the ability to draw out people's
forbidden desires
you seem oddly immune to my charms
referring to them as charms i think
is a bit of a stretch did my father send
you
what's your name lucifer
exactly
so martin what is your take on that
well what's interesting to me is the way
that they portray
the devil if you read the bible
he is against god
now being against god
through this almost becomes cool
and that for me is scary
and people following this
like you said millions and millions
it just shows you maybe where we are at
the point in time
in history of this and what kind of
thinking is instilled in the minds
of the viewers because
if your sympathy is aroused for him
and there are many portions apparently
where is quite a likable character
and your your whole
emotional world is turned upside down
that it becomes very hard to have
sympathy
with the god of the bible correct you
see
previously always you had this picture
of the devil
with horns and a fork
and now they actually come through with
a little bit more
of this subtle lovable character yes
this is more deceiving correct this is
more deceiving and
probably closer to reality exactly
that's
what i also was thinking because he
isn't that
he was a beautiful created being
but martin if you look at the world and
you see the way in which it has gone
then you can see the consequences of his
type of thinking
yes but make no mistake
there are many organizations that
knowingly are in sympathy with the devil
and there are even more organizations
that
unknowingly are in sympathy
with the devil yes and many of them are
religious organizations
this is very interesting we have to make
a deep study
as to how these two adversaries that
we're going to talk about
today the devil lucifer
and michael how they fit into the big
biblical paradigm now i'm not going to
say
too much about the devil anymore i think
we have
quite exhausted the topic definitely and
if you look at
secret doctrine blavatsky lucifer trust
now called lucis trust lucifer
publishing
company it was before and the statements
by blavatsky the statements
by masonic figures
they're pretty blatant that lucifer to
them is the true god
i was invited to come and talk to a
grandmaster of freemasonry who had
septicemia
and there was a possibility that he
would die
and his great argument
was that lucifer definitely was the true
son of god
sure and we had quite a discussion
he actually invited me to go and give my
study to
his lodge but when he recovered he never
came back to me so that never
materialized
so let us from there proceed and talk
about michael
yeah and we know that the adventist view
is that michael and jesus
are one and the same and there are many
many organizations and people out there
that would beg to differ correct so we
have to
look at it carefully so let's have an
open mind
yeah because i think a lot of people
have the idea
if you compare jesus to michael
you're blaspheming because you're trying
to make him
belittle him make him less than what he
is correct
and uh you know some organizations
want to make jesus a created being in
any case
and want to reduce his status so
there are both sides of that coin so
let's just
read a statement in the spirit of
prophecy so that people
in the world can see what do adventists
believe
so this comes from the book the desire
of ages
what does it say about jesus at the
savior's baptism
satan was amongst the witnesses
he saw the father's glory overshadowing
his son he heard the voice of jehovah
testifying to the divinity of jesus
so that's very plain that
the divinity of jesus is not
negotiable definitely
ever since adam's sin the human race had
been cut off from direct communication
with god
the intercourse between heaven and earth
had been
through christ now there we must stop
again
so prior to the coming of christ
according to the statement
the communication between heaven and
earth
was through christ yes he made
it possible the sin as we have
seen in one of our previous what's up
that transgression separated from god
christ was the mediator
from the beginning before the
foundations
of the world were laid from the
beginning
he was the land slain first as
a promise and later as a fulfillment of
that promise
yeah so he was the communication so he
he was the one that
came to the mountain and spoke to moses
correct but we will have to go and
make sure about that right so the
communication was
between man and god
via christ he did use angels
occasionally
but it always went through christ to
the godhead so the intercourse between
heaven and earth had been through
christ but now that jesus had come in
the likeness
of sinful flesh in other words he took
my
humanity the father himself spoke
and he spoke from heaven right this is
my beloved son
he had before communicated with humanity
through christ now he communicated
with humanity in christ
that's a magnificent statement
satan had hoped that god's abhorrence of
evil would bring an eternal separation
between heaven and earth
but now it was manifest that the
connection between god
and man had been restored
so all the communication between god
and man had been through christ
only in christ is it possible to have
access to heaven yes and
that part that you just read about
he communicated with humanity in christ
that just proves again that jesus was
god
absolutely because all humanity was
in christ because he spoke humanity into
existence he created them
let's again have a look at hollywood
now we know that the sympathy
of hollywood is with
the wrong side there is no doubt about
that
the very word hollywood is the witch's
staff
because the witch's staff is made the
divining staff is made from hollywood
and hollywood is nothing other than
jesuit theater and we've discussed that
before and the jesuits
are also in sympathy with lucifer yes
it's a very hard pill to swallow but if
you look at their activities if you look
at their oaths
if you look at their conduct
and if you look at their teaching and
the subtlety thereof
then you will have to come to the
conclusion that they
are the masters of deception
so in the movie michael which depicts
the archangel michael
i wonder how they depict him
we are going to contrast this with
lucifer how did they pick
depict him as this absolute charismatic
charismatic
intelligent bright person now how will
they
portray michael now the actor that
actually portrayed him was
john travolta let's have a look at this
one
[Music]
i just thought halos yes
inner light yes i'm not that kind of
angel
what kind of angel are you michael is an
arc angel he battled
and throw him out of heaven revelation
12 verse 7.
that was a long time ago and then the
bank
came to take the milk bottle
and i prayed for help
until god sent me michael well she was
persistent
you came down and smote
the bank ah branch first iowa bank of
commerce
[Music]
[Applause]
well that was an interesting portrayal
what is your take on that one well
definitely not according to the bible
no okay the last part where he
brings the dog back to life i don't
do angels bring back
anything to life only with the power of
god should they do that right
but here he's doing it basically through
his power
and they depict him as a life-bringer
but he's also a bank robbing smoking
jiving yes partying
individual and
they actually say you know shouldn't you
have a halo or an
inner light and he's not that kind of
angel
and he's an author yes now it's just
interesting
that if you if you have jesuit theater
in your mind
and the very thought that you want to
run someone down or ridicule him
then you must understand that there's no
one who knows scripture better
than the devil himself right yes and his
agents
so he said he was the author of psalms
85.
so it'd be interesting to have a look at
that song isn't that right definitely
so let's have a look at it
psalm 85 in the king james bible has the
title
revive us again
to the chief musician a psalm of the
sons of korah
so it doesn't say that michael the
archangel wrote the song right
no he could have inspired it
but let's not go there yet
lord hast thou been favourable unto thy
land
thou hast brought back the captivity of
jacob
thou hast forgiven the iniquity of thy
people
and thou hast covered all their sins
what does that refer to jesus
jesus that has taken away all thy wrath
that has turned thyself from the
fierceness of thine anger
turn us o god of our salvation
and cause thine anger towards us to
cease
will thou be angry with us forever will
thou
draw out thy anger to all generations
will thou not revive us again that thy
people may rejoice in thee
show us thy mercy o lord and grant us
thou thy salvation who is that talking
about
again jesus this is a a psalm
about a redeemer right
i will hear what god the lord will speak
for he will speak
peace unto his people and to his saints
but let them not turn again to folly
so here is the story of repentance
and staying on the narrow road
surely his salvation is nigh them that
fear him that glory may dwell in our
land
mercy and truth are met together
righteousness and peace have kissed each
other this must be
the most profound verse
in the bible because where did
mercy and truth meet together where did
righteousness and peace kiss each other
at the cross
at the cross there when jesus hung there
their mercy and justice kissed each
other
it was forever displayed to the world
that god is merciful
but that god is a god of justice
and when he said the wages of sin is
death
then justice demanded the execution of
that sentence
and in christ it was and
god is merciful through the very act
mercy could be extended to humanity this
is
such a beautiful psalm
and in this movie what are they doing
ascribing this song
to a vagabond correct isn't that correct
and there's there's lots of intrigue
that you can get in here yes
they maybe acknowledge
that jesus was inspiring this absolutely
but then they mock him they know who
he's referring to
exactly now you're sitting there in the
audience
and all of these little statements and
all of these little things appear
concerning michael and the audience is
distracted by all the
funny things that happen in between
but that implant that goes into the mind
is called neuro linguistic programming
and if you substantiate it with the
visual
it creates an indelible impression upon
the mind
so that you can never think of michael
in the same way again i mean in another
way again
yeah and what's interesting i saw
on the trailer clip the
advertisement for the for the okay then
it was still a video cassette
so say the dvd it says pg so that's only
parental guidance
yes so this is children could also watch
this please let the children watch it
yes that's what they're saying
truth shall spring out of the earth and
righteousness shall look
down from heaven who is our
righteousness
jesus christ is our righteousness yea
the lord shall give that which is good
and our land shall
yield her increase righteousness shall
go before him
and shall set us in the way of his steps
this is one of the most beautiful
psalms regarding the mission
of jesus christ it is not a coincidence
no that they would use that psalm
correct it actually acknowledges
who michael really is it actually
acknowledges who he is
but now the people that are
not in favor of that idea please bear
with us
and let's have a look at the bible study
but before we go there we said it was
jesuit theater
and you know the jesuits today have such
a fair face
they have all these great universities
our great leaders and presidents are
educated
in the jesuit colleges of the world
georgetown university
one of the great universities in the
world has
produced how many presidents it's it's
irrelevant
and let's just read what some authors
have said
about the jesuits now this is a quote
from the jesuits we will gain
control of instruction in law
medicine science education
and so weed out from all books of
instruction
anything injurious to roman catholicism
that's a very bold statement
so the law the medical world
is that prominent in the time that we
are living in now yes
science education
everything has to be so adapted so that
it will
favor roman catholicism
we will mold the thoughts and ideas of
the youth
we will enroll ourselves as protestant
preachers
and college professors in the different
protestant faiths is that a warning yes
no it's actually a promise almost yeah
we will enroll ourselves there sooner or
later we will
undermine the authority of the greek new
testament
of erasmus do they have a particular
pet hate when it comes to the bible yes
just explain to us what is the greek new
testament of erasmus
well erasmus is the one who compiled
the textus receptors on which
the protestants based their translation
of the bible whereas the jesuits
favored the alexandrian text which
had a gnostic origin gnosticism
is a very interesting science we won't
go into that but just
quickly narcissism is exactly what we've
seen in this movie
absolutely turning everything around
jesus or lucifer is this
is actually the good guy yes it's a
reversal
the master of reversal remember he was a
liar from the beginning right and the
truth is
not in him so they hate
the greek new testament of erasmus and
also
those old testament productions which
have dared to raise their head
against the old testament of the vulgate
and against tradition you know if you
look at the vulgate and the
silliness in it jacob worshipped the top
of his staff
whereas the king james would say jacob
worshipped
leaning on top of his staff there's a
big difference right
so their tradition of relic worship
had to be supported so they hate
anything
that confirms the authenticity
of the protestant bible
and thus we will undermine the
protestant reformation that's their
enemy
so that's their aim and they've been
very unfortunately very
successful yes
they early realized there's another
source from
albert henry newman manual of church
history
they early realized the vast importance
of directing higher education
in all their higher education theater
jesuit theater plays an
exceptionally prominent part yes
it's also interesting to me that so
many of the the charismatic figures
not only in the papacy
but also in government were actually
actors
yes ronald reagan comes to my presidency
yes
pope john paul the second comes to mind
they were trained
actors in jesuit schools well trump is
not an actor but he's not shy of the
of oh he's appeared on many television
shows
he is an actor he had his own show the
apprentice absolutely
so educate directing higher education as
a means of gaining control of the lives
of the ablest and
best connected young men and making
trained
intellect subservient to their purposes
that's done through mind manipulations
in when they started with um
jesuit theater society
wasn't ready for some of the things that
they wanted to introduce so they
did it in comedy in the theater yes and
a few
months later it would have been
macbeth for example instilled
ideas into the minds of people
so the marked ability of the jesuit
teachers
their unsurpassed knowledge of human
nature
their affability of manners and their
remarkable
adaptability to the idiosyncrasies and
circumstances of
each individual made them practically
irresistible
when once they came into close relations
with susceptible youth
who gave them this capacity to swing
minds they were to be
perinde et cadava like a corpse
no mind of their own not
rattled by anything absolutely
programmed to cut like a hot knife
through
butter they were
affable they had unsurpassed knowledge
of human nature they had the greatest
teacher of the fallen world that ever
existed lucifer
here's a quote from john adams as what
he wrote
to thomas jefferson and he said i'm not
happy about the rebirth of the jesuits
it's interesting that the jesuits like
the papacy
had a mortal wound a death and a
resurrection yes and
now they're prominent wow yes and the
whole world wondered
after the beast developed its mindset
and they used hollywood with great
success to do that i mean if you just
take
the pope is a jesuit he's put all the
his high officials in
in the catholic church now are jesuits
why why are you not wearing five mosques
one on top of each other
didn't a jesuit trained medic tell you
to do that
he actually acknowledge it we and we
showed all of this
yes we don't have to go there swarms of
them will present themselves
under more disguises ever taken by even
a chief of the bohemians as
printers writers publishers school
teachers etc
if ever an association of people
deserved
eternal damnation on this earth or in
hell
it is the society of loyola
this is history this is a fact but
people tend to forget history
especially when history is rewritten or
erased so let's
talk about michael because this is what
we want to
discuss today right yes so we've seen
the contrast the elevation of lucifer in
the world
in the philosophies let me just go to
the philosophy of the united nations
the united nations prayer room
the organizations associated with the
united nations
it is mind-boggling it is so
blatantly luciferian yes and so
wonderfully acceptable and
michael this slob
smoking bank robbing
individual
so let's look at the bible dictionary
this is the eastern's bible dictionary
what it says about
michael the definition is who is like
god
actually the definition is who is what
god is that's pretty
direct right so the title given to one
of
the chief angels actually this is a bit
of a misnomer as we will see
he had special charge of israel as a
nation
he disputed with satan about the body of
moses he is also represented as
warning against that old serpent called
the devil and satan which deceives the
whole world
revelation 12 7-9 so he's the great
adversary of satan there's a great
conflict
between michael and satan
yes and that's called the great
controversy
correct now this word
archangel it is used very
broadly in the world and
if you study catholicism and and you
look at their writings you will see they
have a number of archangels listed
there's raphael and gabriel
and all of them they're listed as
archangels
if you look at some of the other
organizations in the world there are
many archangels
but if you read the king james version
the word
archangel only appears
twice and here are the two verses
1 thessalonians 4 16 for the lord
himself shall descend from heaven with a
shout
with the voice of the archangel and
with the trump of god and the dead in
christ
shall rise first in jude 1
9 it says yet michael the archangel
when contending with the devil he
disputed about the body of
moses does not bring against him a
railing accusation but said the lord
rebuked thee so
two verses where we have this word
archangel
and in the first one it's also not an
archangel v the archangel
and once here it is associated with
michael
the bible actually never associates the
word
archangel with any other angel no even
gabriel
and interesting neither does the spirit
of prophecy
really now this first verse over here we
can expand on that one a little bit
but first let's have a look at the
definition here's taylor's
definition of the word archangel
and his definition is archangel
or chief of the angels
port of speech noun and it's masculine
it's interesting that angels are often
depicted as feminine right
particularly in roman catholic
portrayals
on murals etc and babies
yes and uh it's masculine
and it literally means chief
of the angels now let's go back to this
verse in thessalonians for the lord
himself shall descend from heaven with a
shout
with the voice of the archangel and
with the trump of god and the dead in
christ
shall rise first so
the lord will descend when they use this
word
lord in the new testament it's the
equivalent of the word
in the old testament in the new
testament it's curious in the old
testament
it's jave or java
so he will come with the voice of the
archangel
now let's just go to a parallel text
john 5
26 as the father has life in himself
so has he given to the son to have
life in himself
and has given him authority to
execute judgment also because he
is the son of man
marvel not at this for the hour is
coming in which
all that are in the graves shall hear
his voice whose voice shall they hear
jesus the son of man son of man
whose voice is that it's the voice of
the archangel
so in these two texts you have
the reality that the voice of the
archangel
is the voice of the son of man
now this title son of man as we have
discussed before
comes from daniel chapter 7.
it is the one who came to the ancient of
days
and he is the one that took his seat in
the judgment
yes now all judgment was given
to so here obviously we have a link
between the archangel's voice
and the voice of the son of god one and
the same
what's interesting for me as well is if
you look at the sentence construction
it's for me it comes through that
and the dead in christ shall rise first
so if you follow it from
with the voice of the archangel these
dating christ will rise when they hear
the voice
when they wear the voice but that says
and the dead in christ so
this links that archangel with christ
also
absolutely so this is a very powerful
linkage that we have
but we have to go deeper than that we
have to go deeper
remember also in the back of your mind
that the word michael means the one who
is what god is
so let's go back in history and we look
at exodus chapter 3
verse 2. in the old testament we
often read the angel of the lord
now that is a very specific title and
the word
angel there if you look it up means
messenger we can look it up in a moment
the angel of the lord appeared unto him
this is now moses in a flame of fire
out of the midst of a bush and he looked
and behold the bush
burned with fire and the bush was not
consumed so here was a miracle
and associated with the miracle was the
angel of the lord
verse 5 says and he said
draw not nigh hither this is not the
angel of the lord speaking
put of thy shoes from off thy feet
for the place whereon thou standest is
holy ground
moreover he said i
am the god of thy fathers
the god of abraham the god of
isaac and the god of jacob
and moses hid his face for he was afraid
to look upon god
so very clear that the angel of the lord
is god right also the fact that he
declared
the place where the angel of the lord
was standing
as holy ground so we have to
go a little bit further so let's have a
look at this
angel and god in the bible because it
says i am the lord thy god.
so the first word there for angel
was malok from an unused root
meaning to dispatch as a deputy
a messenger specifically of god
that is an angel also a prophet priest
or teacher
ambassador angel king
messenger now we read in the beginning
the statement in the spirit of prophecy
that jesus was
the means by which the godhead
communicated with humanity
so here the angel of the lord says that
he is
god so the word used there is elohim
this is interesting it says
gods in the ordinary sense but
specifically used
in the plural thus specifically with the
article
of the supreme god
let us make man
in our image
occasionally applied by way of deference
to
magistrates and sometimes as a
superlative to
angels so angels can also be called
messengers they are messengers
exceeding god
goddess great
judges mighty so there are many
applications
but the fact that he received
worship yes is beyond doubt
the pinnacle of the argument because
only god may receive words
isaiah chapter 63 verse 7
i will mention the loving-kindness of
the lord
that is yahweh
and the praises of the lord
according to all that the lord has
bestowed on us
and the great goodness towards the house
of israel
which he has bestowed on them according
to his mercies
and according to the multitude of his
lovingkindnesses
for he said surely they are my people
children that will not lie so he was
their savior this is now
the lord is also the savior
in all their afflictions he was
afflicted and the angel of his presence
saved them and his love
and in in his love and
in his pity he redeemed them
and he bear them and he carried them
all the days of all so now we have
another link yes we have jehovah
the name jave
coupled to savior
coupled to angel of his presence
coupled to a savior coupled to
a redeemer coupled to a
sustainer that carried them
all the days of old who's it referring
to
jesus jesus so is
jesus here called
angel of his presence yes
yes certainly jesus is called angel of
his presence so we had
the burning bush and now we have another
example
let's let's go further now that also
linked him to yahweh
that also linked him to yahweh a title
by the way
which is applied to jesus in the new
testament as
kurios and in the old testament
both the father and the son are referred
to as
jehovah genesis 48 verse 16 this was
jacob's blessing
that he pronounced on the sons of joseph
and again it says the angel which
redeemed me
from all evil bless the lads
and let my name be named on them
and the name of my fathers abraham
and isaac and let them grow into a
multitude in the midst of the earth
who is the one that was to bless them
the angel which redeemed me
so here again you have a reference to
the word angel yes and redemption yes
now the only one who can redeem us
because
there is no other name
under heaven and earth whereby we can be
saved other than the name christ jesus
so again you have a link between the
angel
of his presence the angel that redeemed
in the old testament the angel of the
lord
that appeared in the burning bush
now revelation 12 7
and there was war in heaven michael
and his angels fought
against the dragon and the dragon fought
and his angels and prevailed not
neither was their place found in
any more in heaven so the great conflict
was between michael and his angels
and the devil that old serpent was cast
out
and his angel and he was cast out so
there was war
the leader and the captain of the host
of the heavenly
host was michael yes and the one
of the devil's side was lord
so that was the conflict now let's just
be very careful here
let's go to the old testament
and we look at a verse in joshua 5.
and it came to pass when joshua was by
jericho so this is when the children of
israel
were entering into canaan after their 40
years sergeant
now finally they were entering
and jericho was the first point of
conflict that he lifted up his eyes and
looked and behold there stood a man
over against him with a sword drawn in
his hand
and joshua went unto him and said unto
him art thou
for us or for our adversaries
and he said nay as
captain of the host of the lord
am i now come and joshua fell
on his face to the earth and did
worship and said unto him
what says my lord unto his servant
and the captain of the lord's host said
unto joshua loose thy shoes from off thy
foot for the place whereon thou standest
is holy where did you read that before
moses moses and
joshua worshipped yes
whom did he worship it must be god
you must have worshipped god because you
may not worship
anyone else and he was the captain of
the lord's host
now who in revelation was the captain
of the heavenly host michael the
archangel michael the archangel are we
getting a picture here
definitely okay so
this is this is a very important
parallel
because he is the conqueror
he is the mighty angel with his sword
drawn
and it's fascinating that joshua
actually
went up to him to confront him
but when he realized who it was he
fell and worshipped and he had to take
off his shoes
and this falling down and worshipping
this angel is in contrast with john
that fell falls down and worships the
angel
in revelation that was a normal angel
because then they said no
no no stan i'm i'm a fellow servant with
you
correct so worship god yes so
the fact that the captain of the lord's
host
the fact that the angel of his presence
the fact that the angel that redeemed
all receive worship and
give blessings yes is
proof that we are dealing with god
correct
and he's the one that's communicating
with humanity
so it must be jesus correct so the one
who is what god
is michael is his angelic name
and is a portrayal of what he is but he
has
other names as well for example if you
go to isaiah
there are many titles that he has and
some of the titles
as you know are to us a child
is born and he will be called
emmanuel immanuel which means
god with us so it's a description
of what he is doing yes and there is
also
called almighty god
so that's very interesting it's just
something interesting that i thought of
now
it also says when we get to heaven
we'll get a new name so you'll also get
your angelic
name yes that will be different to what
you've got
yes because it will portray the
character
that you are supposed to develop
now let's just have a look at a few
other examples in the old testament
if you look at the parents of samson for
example
the angel of the lord appeared first
to the mother of samson and then later
to
the father of samson in judges 13
21 it says but the angel of the lord did
no more appear to manoa
and to his wife then manoa knew
that he was an angel of the lord
and manoah said unto his wife we shall
surely die because we have
seen god so
when the bible speaks about the angel of
the lord
he's the one that went ahead of them in
the fiery pillar and in the pillar of
cloud
that is the angel of the lord it was
jesus
all along and if we go to the vision of
zechariah
it says in zechariah 3 verse 1 and he
showed me
joshua the high priest standing before
the angel of the lord
and satan standing at his right hand to
resist him
and the lord said unto satan the lord
rebuked thee o
satan even the lord that has chosen thee
jerusalem rebuked thee
is this not a brand plucked out of the
fire
where did we read the words the lord
rebuke thee
satan in jude contending
with the body of moses so the words that
we read here
the lord rebuke thee o satan are the
exact words
that we find in the book of jude yes
and they are spoken by jesus jesus
because
it says michael and here it is michael
now
who is the god of the resurrection
jesus jesus he's the one
who will call the dead to life yes
on the last day so here's another link
the exact same words
michael the angel of the lord but the
angel of the lord is not normal angel
because he receives worship correct
we have seen god exactly
the links are undisputable i hope so
let's go to the visions of daniel
because now we're getting to the crux of
the matter
daniel 10 13 but the prince of the
kingdom of persia
withstood me one and twenty days
but lo michael one of the chief princes
came to help me and i remained there
with the kings of
persia this is a fascinating verse
now if we go to this one of the chief
princes and we look it up it says
first in place time or rank
ancestor before beginning
eldest first foremost
former of old time
what's it referring to jesus because
that's all the tribute
attributes of god correct so when it
says one of the chief princes
then it must be referring to the godhead
because they are often called princes
now the prince of the kingdom of persia
was not the earthly prince because
an angel like gabriel would go
and that prince would be gone right yes
so what happened when the king of
babylon
was confronted with the finger of god
his knees smoked together
so exactly the same thing happens here
so the the prince of the kingdom of
persia
is the super prince standing behind
the earthly one that's lucifer yes
and it's interesting that lucifer
held up gabriel because we know that
this was the angel gabriel
yes and april then summoned the aid of
michael one of the chief princes of the
godhead
of the godhead and he came
and got rid of the problem yeah
there's only one who can withstand the
power of the devil now this is an
amazing verse to me
because it just shows the character of
god
we've spoken of this before but let's
mention it again
when god threw satan out of heaven
he robbed him of his position
but he never took any of his power away
yes
so he was still mightier than gabriel
gabriel could not get through
it took michael to do this yeah
that's his loving character correct
he wanted to show the whole universe
that even if he didn't take away
anything from lucifer he didn't need to
because his true character will come out
will come out
and and lucifer would have said hey
you've clipped my wings
we don't have a fair contest but god
allowed him to manifest his full
capacity
and we can see where the world has gone
as a consequence
where the sympathy is lying but now the
other thing
is how careful
must we be of the sin of presumption
that's the most dangerous sin
because that's the sin that let adam and
eve fall
correct and how many preachers in the
world
treat satan like a beaten dog
and gabriel couldn't get
past him but an earthly
fallen being commands
all of this power if it weren't for
michael
we would have no power nothing if it
weren't for the one who
is what god is we would have no
power the only way to conquer
the devil and his angels is through the
power of christ
correct so daniel chapter 10 verse 21
but i will show thee that which is noted
in the scripture of truth
and there is none that holdeth with me
in these things but
michael your prince
who is our prince jesus christ is there
another
no no other name daniel 12
1 and at that time shall michael
stand up the great prince which standeth
for the children of
thy people and there shall be a time of
trouble such as never was
since there was a nation even to that
same time and at that time thy people
shall be delivered every one that shall
be
found written in the book now this is an
amazing verse this verse
refers to michael shall stand
up what does that mean
we need to think about that michael
will stand up he is
sitting at the moment on the judgment
throne yes all judgment has been given
unto him and
we did a series or we did a what's up on
uh the judgment
yes and when he stands
up from the judgment throne
then probation is closed and when
probation is closed
then there will be a time of trouble
such as never was and we are
this close to that time
when the investigative judgment comes to
an end
that's when michael will stand up from
the throne of judgment
and the phase of executive judgment
will commence the plagues will fall
and at that time the promise is
that we will believe it the delivered
the fact that he stands
up tells us who he is correct
he is jesus because all
judgment has been given yes unto him all
authority
and judge everything so when he stands
up
he says now it's finished now it's
finished and the great decree
will go out just as it was at the
cross it is finished the price for
redemption was paid
but sin still continued to this very day
just switch on your television and you
will see
that it is the case so
the close of probation led him who is
just
remain just let him who is unjust
let him remain unjust that decree will
go
up when jesus stands up from the
judgment seat
and like you said we are on the verge we
are now in a time of this earth that we
have to decide are we standing
on michael's side on lucifer's side that
is the choice that we have to make
and we must never forget not only has
all
judgment been given unto him
but there is no other name under heaven
and earth
whereby we may be saved other than the
name
christ jesus he is the captain of the
lord's host
he is the captain of our salvation he is
our redeemer
he is the son of god
shall we pray yes please heavenly father
what an amazing story of a great
conflict between good and evil
and here on earth the great
story of the bible has been twisted
out of all proportions and portrayed in
such a way
that people have sympathy with the
archdeceiver
open our eyes lord that we may
see that we may make right choices
is my prayer in jesus name amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe to our channel
click here to get notifications click on
the bell
to watch the next video click here
thank you and we'll see you again